nick is with us in Cincinnati hi Nick
how are you good good talking to you
Dave you too man what's up
living the dream humor so they tell me
I've got a question regarding some of my
stocks I've just got a few shares that
my grandpa got us into when I was
younger and they've done well with
Disney and I don't see Disney ever going
anywhere but up from here but um I've
seen a ton of ton of buzz on Bitcoin a
lot of buzz on Bitcoin yeah and I'm
watching it from the the $10,000
benchmark kind of take a dip and I'm
kind of wondering if I should maybe pull
my stocks out and go into that market no
no no under no circumstances I would not
hell no I do not have a dime in Bitcoin
and I'm a multimillionaire yeah I'm
curious okay I mean I really wanted to
talk to you since I've kind of jumped
jumped into learning about this I
haven't learned much but I really wanted
to know what you know as you know it's
called cryptocurrency correct mm-hmm and
you know what currency is did you know
that I can take a green piece of paper
with a president's face on it and lay it
on a counter anywhere in America and for
that matter and most counters around the
world and someone will pick it up and
trade a good or a service for MIT it's
called a dollar right yeah 100 dollar
bill did you know that green piece of
paper has no value at all the only
reason the only reason that green piece
of papers has value is that you all have
all agreed to trade it yeah yeah I
understand
so it's disagreed on that it's trust
that's what it's based on and it's based
on and you know what Trust is based on
stability and predictability Bitcoin has
no stability and no predictability and
no trust it's all over the place it is
going to be a volatile freaking
nightmare until it settles in some day
in the future I kinda like the idea of
it
and I kind of like the idea that it's
unregulated and it's laying out there
and the you know in the Netherlands but
it's got to it's got to stabilize and
it's got to develop a level of trust
because right now dude you're in the
okay Corral and everybody's got their
guns drawn somebody's going to die yeah
I keep saying that's like the Wild West
and the gold rush right it's exactly
what it is you know what did that you
know what else did that in the Latin in
the last decade gold oh yeah that is
true I told people not to buy gold
don't buy gold I don't have any gold
except cufflinks and one watch don't buy
gold don't buy gold Dave you're crazy
man everybody's making so much money
gold is going up goes $1,800 Dave what's
gold right now 600 it sucks people yeah
we hit a sell point I know they've lost
fortunes and so what you're trying to do
is predict where the bullets gonna hit
in the wild wild west
man I playing my money on that and let
me just tell you your grandpa reached
down from heaven smack you you use the
money he gave you to do this wouldn't he
all right
wouldn't ya I could kind of be that yeah
I can definitely see that I my opinion
you want to do people I know some of you
people would pick coins you're going
nuts now just like you go people with
nuts but you know what I ain't losing
money on gold and I won't be losing
money on Bitcoin hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]